[Musique]
à
en plein coeur de marseille dans le 1er
arrondissement le quartier de noailles
[Musique]
dans les rues une grande partie des
habitants sont d'origine étrangère du
maroc de la tunisie de l'algérie
c'est ici qu'on croise les chibanis les
anciens en arabe des retraités
maghrébins célibataire rester en france
après leur vie de travail
pour beaucoup de ces vieux messieurs
c'est l'heure de la promenade
pour d'autres c'est l'occasion
d'arrondir les femmes mois
mohamed et tunisiens il a 64 ans ils
vont des téléphones d'occasion
il est une toute petite retraite c'était
un hommage et ils sont là depuis 40 ou
50 ont beaucoup d'entre vivote en
vendant ce qu'ils peuvent
chez ahmed s'épiler gant de toilette un
petit business qui lui rapporte 5 à 10
euros par le chinois arrivé en france en
64 il a travaillé sur des chantiers la
vérité moins cher
voilà mais le magasin il a déjà formé
manas dans le quartier tous les
commerçants connaissent leurs
difficultés à boucler les fins de mois
ces vieux travailleurs ont un peu tout
cela mais l'histoire des patrons qui les
faisait travailler soit disant de
déclarer n'hésitez pas à déclaré la
piste fils de baye mais c'est pas la
caisse de retraite
ça fait qu'une fois au but de travail
j'en connais un qui va demander à la
retraite
mes patrons fils ou à l'époque c'est ce
qu'il fit pas hésité en fait à la main
mais non alors le type il a trimé trimer
mais la retraite est touché
venir quand tu y vas la caisse de
retraite ou sans doute isolé constater
tout jamais
toutes ces années ces hommes ont cru en
la france depuis toujours marseille
c'est la porte d'entrée des jeunes
d'afrique du nord en 1954 ils n'étaient
que deux cent cinquante mille établis en
france un chiffre qui va presque tripler
à la fin des années 60 à l'époque il y
avait du travail
ils étaient les bienvenus
[Musique]
aujourd'hui une partie de ces hommes vit
toujours à quelques centaines de mètres
du port où ils ont débarqué dans le
quartier de belsunce
l'endroit est en pleine rénovation c'est
ici qu'ils ont vécu dans le provisoire
dans l'idée de retourner un jour au pays
vieillir près de leur famille
mais le retour est plus difficile que
prévu ils vivent toujours dans les mêmes
hôtels meublés des hôtels pas chers aux
enseignes un peu trompeuse au confort
très incertain
c'est dans un de ces hôtels meublés que
nous avons rencontré monsieur moix iba
il a 66 ans il est algérien et vit dans
cette petite chambre depuis 30 ans sans
chauffage
il est arrivé en 1969 et il a même gardé
le papier qu'il a présentée aux
douaniers français le jour de son
arrivée officielle la place cartier tout
à l'époque il n'y avait pas de quotas il
n'était pas question d'immigration
choisie
l'arrivée de jeunes travailleurs
algériens était même prévue par les
accords d'evian entre la france et
l'algérie
il suffisait aux candidats d'être en
bonne santé pour obtenir le temps pour
d'entrée c'est la france qui demande des
travailleurs à ses passagers un mois
j'ai passé avec la visite milité avec la
visite dr français je passe les sages je
passe avec le gps ça va aussi bas bol
des basses laissant télé d'ici bas prix
et va saigner vous voyez avec la
préfecture
après quand je commence je travaille si
les farc télé valoir kahn est sidérante
la chambre l'effroyable sauvage et rien
du tout et comment cette maladie et
william à deux voiliers haweij a
bafouillé rien du tout
la plupart des hôtels meublés du
quartier sont complètement délabré c'est
ce que vient constater ce jour-là un
huissier envoyé par le tribunal de
marseille
il vient faire un état des lieux pour
savoir si cet immeuble doit être
réhabilité trois très vieux messieurs se
partagent ces toilettes à tous les
étages c'est le même un confort
aux policiers il ya un carreau cassé on
n'a pas de voler on a un point d'eau
avec de l'eau froide n'y a pas d'eau
chaude donc ici même chose
l'un d'eux
deux équipements sanitaires n'est pas
aux normes et on n'a pas de chauffage et
la prese les brûler j'ai mis le
chauffage
voilà la chambre d'un des locataires
depuis dans une chambre dans un réduit
que ce monsieur occupe depuis le matin
[Musique]
ça vous arrive souvent de voir ce type
de logement malheureusement oui c'est
régulièrement harcelés centre ville de
marseille et avec des populations
retraités parce que ça vous a réparé en
que en majeure partie des populations
autres été victime d'origine
ensuite les autres champs en fait tout
l'immeuble est un immense courants d'air
parcouru par les rats et rongé par les
moisissures
parce que je cachais disent plus non
c'est comme ça je vais en prendre effet
et on a une chance une surface d'un
mètre cinquante comme remède au total
six mètres carrés je crois qu'à l'heure
actuelle les cellules dans les
établissements financiers ni d'un cias
ont six mètres carrés je crois savoir
ses hommes ne se sont jamais révolter
contre leurs conditions de vie ici pas
plus qu'au travail monsieur moix iba se
rappelle de ses années sur les chantiers
j'ai pas aller la mer détour par capa ya
pas de masquer rien dit toi va non wim
naya les masques et où il y aurait du
palais le masque d'une paille rien dit
ou la base de travail comme celle-là
maire d'hendaye tout oui la musique à
varanasi bonne monnaie travailleurs
menacés bonnes y aller avant moi je
travaille des traces magie magelio
régiment je viens là la hauteur et
maintenant je my à l'apparat qu'il ya du
chômage et les tours avaya bat
chumbawumba droit direct comme déclaré
cana va aujourd'hui à la retraite
monsieur moi il va être toujours
déchirée entre ces deux pays
sa femme et ses six enfants vivant en
algérie pendant 37 ans il a dû se
contenter de les voir grandir sur des
photos et aujourd'hui ça continue lui
doit rester en france pour bénéficier de
ses droits sa retraite la sécurité
sociale de tout ce qu'il a acquis en
travaillant
et là je viens ici je vais titrant
marcato maj de régler avec le papier
appelé givat et seydoux m'a trop mal à
part l'algérie sitôt un l et r toujours
eh oui
mais ces allers-retours cost aujourd'hui
beaucoup de soucis à ses vieux retraité
de marseille à cheval entre deux pays
l'équilibré précaire d'autant que de
plus en plus ils ont le sentiment pour
leur demande de choisir
c'est dans un petit restaurant du
quartier de belsunce que nous avons
rencontré monsieur besnéhard il a 72 ans
dont 45 entre l'algérie et la france est
tout seul toujours depuis six mois le
vieux monsieur à des tracas
administratifs d'un nouveau genre une
des seules personnes qui tentent de
l'aider c'est nordine abouakil il anime
une association qui défend les retraités
célibataires du quartier centre ville
pour tous
[Musique]
nordine se bat pour faire rénover des
hôtels et empêcher des expulsions mais
aujourd'hui mohamed besnéhard lui a
demandé de venir pour autre chose
ses revenus et ses droits sociaux sont
menacés les temps ont bien changé depuis
l'époque où le vieux monsieur rêvait
d'une terre de bienveillance et de
prospérité
une hta compte être le bea français
radio la wii et des idées dans la tête
il dormait avec la france c'est une
manière de dire je rêvais avec la france
150 ça quand il est là et il des tons
qui travaillait il dit la baisse il a
toujours eu des périodes longues de chez
des patrons parce que tant qu'ils
travaillaient ils étaient bien l'idée
que les périodes de chômage était très
très réduite c'est à dire que il
quittait un employeur lundi vendredi
lents trouver un autre il touche
aujourd'hui une retraite de 500 euros
toute cette vie de travail est résumé
dans ce sac feuilles de paye feuille
d'impôts il a tout conservé
précieusement
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui aux
yeux du fisc
le vieux monsieur ne passerait pas
suffisamment de temps à marseille pour
être considéré comme un résident
français à cause de ces fameuses aller
retour pour aller voir sa famille comme
le font tous les chibanis il pourrait
perdre ses droits
ça c'est la vie la déclaration des
droits et la vie 2003 par contre ici on
a la déclaration 2004 que monsieur
reçus préimprimés de la part des
services fiscaux on l'a invité à remplir
cette déclaration il a rempli et rendu
en temps et en heure parce que là je
vois 24 mars et au jour d'aujourd'hui il
fait partie de ces très nombreux
retraités du quartier à qui on refuse la
vis fiscal et qu'est ce que ça peut
avoir comme conséquence pour lui de ne
pas avoir l'avis fiscal en fait ce
monsieur peut très bien se voir priver
de toutes les aides qui sont soumises à
conditions de revenus le minimum
vieillesse de mener mon vieillesse
l'aide au logement
la gratuité des bus pour les personnes
de plus de 65 ans sont une condition de
revenus toutes ces conditions
perdu dans ses papiers monsieur bénard
est inquiet il n'est pas sûr de
continuer à bénéficier de la totalité de
ses droits sociaux
nordine lui s'interroge est ce une façon
de chasser ces gens du centre ville en
rénovation est ce une façon de les
renvoyer dans leur pays
en tous les cas dans le centre de
marseille
ils sont quatre mille à vivre dans la
même incertitude
ils ont coutume de se retrouver ici
place des oubliés comme ils disent pour
prendre le soleil ou le café pour être
résident français ces retraités doivent
donc passer six mois et un jour en
france
encore faut-il arriver à le prouver au
fisc et dans cette vie d'aller retour
c'est un véritable casse tête
ce petit monsieur mohamed est dans ce
cas plusieurs personnes ont pris fait et
cause pour lui parce qu'il lui manque le
fameux à vis fiscal
il vient de se voir supprimer son
minimum vieillesse la moitié de ses
revenus avec le vieux monsieur
le petit groupe de marseillais seront à
l'hôtel des impôts pour le soutenir dans
ses démarches
mohamed à ses quittances de loyer il a
tous ses papiers pour ton apparemment ça
ne suffit pas l'employé du fisc ne lui
fait pas confiance et lui réclame son
ancien passeport pour vérifier ces dates
d'entrée sortie en france l'année
précédente alors qu'il a renouvelés vous
savez pertinemment que quand celui-là
l'ancien passeport garder le gars il est
détruite au fils cadet à marseille aussi
nous dit risque d'obliger la confiance
grâce à monsieur dire à ce monsieur qui
est retraité l'heure actuelle pourquoi
on luttera casse ma vie mohamed repart
sans avoir eu gain de cause
il a 80 ans 40 ans de travail en france
et depuis ce mois-ci 400 euros par mois
pour vivre